Tiny tools are a big part of our
technological legacy, of who we are as a
species. Prior to our study most people
assumed that miniaturization was a recent
phenomenon, that it was something that
happened late in our evolutionary
history, associated with things like
microchips and modern technologies. And
what we've actually shown, is that the
process of miniaturization is probably
the most important and long-term
technological phenomena related to our
evolution. It's been there for almost
ever. To most people, a tool like this,
a miniaturized stone flake, seems pretty
feeble. But in fact, these are some of the
most effective tools that our species
and our ancestors have ever made.
It marks key behavioral changes for our
species, the first of them being when we
started to systematically use stone
tools to cut meat, the second one when we
started to develop high speed weapon
systems about a hundred thousand years
ago, and lastly, when we dealt with some
of the most challenging aspects of
climate change at the end of the last
ice age. Small tools were there to help
us and they have been and they continue
to be, and it's one of our lasting
legacies as a technological species.